thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another careful boys
we're very careful boys and today we are
currently off the Record oh really can't
trick this guy and today we're talking
about we are so I was in the Discord the
JK Discord check it out patreon eh you
gotta be a patreon member to understand
what you were talking about there's a
little bit you have a cold
[Laughter]
somebody brought up what is the best
video game of all time GTA has now
nobody argue with me [__] you yeah you
know what end the video that is true if
you're if you're talking about best in
terms of Revenue and Longevity you would
no we're gonna go way more subjective
here just yeah it has to say what they
think okay let's go subject let's go
yeah let's go ball time to you to you me
yeah stats not yeah [__] people yeah
otherwise we're just like oh Minecraft
has the most numbers can we start with
who is the best video game player
because I'm the worst so I'll give the
most
your answer would be
I am the best Street Fighter oh that's a
good
my favorite one my favorite one is is
the one where you can get Hulk up in
there Street Fighter versus Capcom that
one yup and then you could
Marvel Capcom no no no so you're like
you could be right here right and then
you press a couple buttons and then it
[__] switches out and another mother
it's MVC
yeah Marvel's Capcom was the bomb that's
still good they still compete
professionally with that game yeah yeah
we played it why didn't they make a
Marvel vs DC Video Game oh it'll be the
sickest [__] game because Marvel was
like I don't want to [__] work with
you guys because because Marvel will be
carrying DC on their backs
Superman well DC is against uh Mortal
Kombat
Joker what if you could play as Joker
that'd be crazy yeah you can you can see
he shoots a gun [__] but you choose a
gun with a bang like Marvel versus DC is
my that's my dream game that'd be
that's one of her moves opens her top
there's a there's like a Warner Brothers
uh version now I don't know if it's out
here super smash one it's all the IPS
that wonder about multiverses yeah yeah
oh yeah that's like Smash Bros yeah yeah
oh really
LeBron James is one of the characters
that's so dumb the [__] out really yeah
yeah
he throws a basketball at you Eric bows
his voice is in that game oh cool a lot
of the characters yeah do you guys
remember Shaq Foo oh yes what's that
arguably not a bad game not a bad game
it's really stupid it was just like a
fighting game but you're Shaq yeah and
you fight like Intergalactic enemies
like it's so crazy how about we do
categories what's your guys's favorite
games then your favorite games yeah
categories might be more helpful because
then it's more of a fun conversation all
right yeah okay here's overall do
overall first yeah overall first overall
I would I would say like uh I would say
Sims
revolutionarily that game covers so much
it's so deep and the data involved in it
is so like Limitless plus they opened up
the uh ability to to mod it so the game
it just lives forever yeah yeah they did
open it up for GTA because GTA was
airplane mode
another one that's revolutionary is
Counter-Strike
dude Counter-Strike is a mod that's
what's crazy is this right yeah of
Half-Life right yeah so is Team Fortress
I think yeah Wolfenstein was my first
experience to that whole point of view
well the science type the crazy thing is
how Counter-Strike spawned an entire
industry of PC cafes like being more
popular isn't that crazy that's insane
like it became a business model people
bought computers they dim the lights
yeah people got murdered you got shot by
gangsters yeah that was my first
Obsession though where you stay like for
hours on the computer was uh Warcraft oh
yeah Warcraft and then Starcraft came
out yeah and then [__] Command and
Conquer Command and Conquer Empires all
that [__] where you just build [__]
armies yeah Pirates yeah hurricanes
golden [__] chopped trees
heck is crazy sifu you want to say that
one no well I think my that's funny no
that game is great though what Seafood
he likes that what game is that it's
just like a it's like a fighting you're
like Kung Fu Master and you're just like
going through like what would you call
like a dungeon press L2 to kiss
every time you like die you get older
but if you're older you're better it's
like it's like a homage like the old
school like Hong Kong style the fighting
super technical yeah yeah yeah yeah but
I think my favorite game what console is
it on I think it's like PlayStation and
Xbox everything my favorite game
probably overall was probably Red Dead
wow wait two the first one I haven't
beat Red Dead Two the very first Red
Dead yeah I love it I love Red Dead
Redemption the story oh Red Dead
Redemption wait it was red dead the
first one's revolver oh I never played
that one yeah but Red Dead Redemption is
the that's the game changer for sure
it's a sucky shitty game is that
Rockstar soap yeah but it's like pre
they hadn't figured it out completely
but John Marston Red Dead Redemption I
just love the story and how like is the
Mars does yeah dude it was it was just
such a cool game it was like I was I was
in high school or something I think it's
it's brilliant yeah it's great but now I
really like God of War I just I just
finished it oh you're in his PS5 you got
the new one no no the first 2018 one
okay that one is really good because I
think nowadays like I'm not in a big
like competitive gamer I think I like
the story of it I think uh that's why I
like GTA if you're like on offline mode
you're just in story mode story mode
crazy good it's like being in a movie
and everyone's talking about the last of
us and I tried playing The Last of Us
for the first time like when I first got
the PlayStation and I had headphones on
and it was a little too scary
eating my face and I was like this is
[__] real scary like actual scary
games are like really scary though
what's the scariest game you played
pacify that should freak me out that's
why it's literally a horror game it's
one where you're just like you're given
puzzles and there's a house and you just
gotta figure out how to like get out of
it but then if you don't then like
[__] like like the ring girl type
[__] with like hair will be like
you don't get the puzzles right yeah and
did you just hear it in your earphones
you know what I mean it's crazy what's
that game we used to play it was like
slenderman slenderman yeah I don't like
that either can you play dead space I
was freaking the [__] out that's just
scary I know I don't like it the the
jump scares of the game Resident Evil
was like that middle it was scary but
like even that's too scary for me I'm
too [__] there I'm [__] I'm a big
[__] crowd [__] though yeah yeah I got
into Metal Gear I [__] up dude that's
my favorite I mean that's the freaking
Metal Gear Symphony No your thought is
my favorite game when I was a kid like I
was too stupid for the OG metal gear and
then I always die and [__] and I'm like
[__] this game right I wanted to [__]
do some Space Invaders or what [__] I
don't know Mario Brothers but then later
on I think that tainted my view of metal
gear when everyone else got into it I
was like I ain't playing that [__] I see
yeah and then I think Metal Gear got
really good because the stories and
everything and I never played it once
metal gear Final Fantasy the two like
big [__] games that everyone got into
I never touched Metal Gear had a really
cool function where it messed with your
real life like
um senses so like there was they put
this thing in the game where like
there's a point where you're fighting
this one guy and he like claims that he
knows everything about you psychomantis
yeah and it reads your memory card and
he goes you like playing Mega Man don't
you whoa that you have a save file from
another game
and you're like
and another kid you don't you don't
[__] know you're like how the [__]
does he know [__] yeah and another
another game that did that really really
well uh this game called undertale that
like I'm not gonna be spoiling anything
because it's been out for a long time
but there's a crazy thing in undertale
where the programmer this genius guy one
dude made the entire game himself all
the assets music Graphics programming
all of it and he did this crazy thing
where um no matter what system you're
playing on right he does this thing
where you fight the first boss and you
in the story you have a feeling you
don't want to kill this boss because his
first boss is basically your mother and
then um you're like hitting there right
and then
uh her life bar is like nowhere near
being dead but like if you hit her this
much she just dies and you're like oh
[__] no what the [__] so then like you
reset you like naturally as a person
you're like ah now let me reset I don't
I didn't want to kill her so you go back
and then you uh don't kill her and then
she's alive everything's cool you go to
the next room and this [__] demonic
flower pops up from the ground and goes
I know what you did oh [__] you killed
her and you went back and tried to undo
it yeah and it [__] like you don't see
it coming at all because they know
everybody's gonna do that that's what
they punched and then it goes It goes
and then he literally goes like he's
it's like makes that setting of like you
thought you were in a normal game but
you're not whoa [__] [__] with the
undertale yeah it [__] with you so hard
console does that come on it's a game
where you can go from beginning to end
without killing a single thing and it
shows you the consequences of reaction
so if you go things out dude no yes if
you go through it and you kill normal
enemies you realize later that you get
to a village the first Village and it's
just less populated because those
enemies were the citizens of that place
it's fine God damn
I know about this what's the a
like 34.
you can't be pregnant okay you're gonna
be a homeowner yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
dude it's so tight yeah one of the
biggest jackpots I ever hit was uh one
of my friends that I met in school his
dad was a arcade technician what what a
score go to his house and his garage was
just lined with arcade machines but you
know the part we put the quarters in all
of them just opened so we could play
Street Fighter unlimited and as soon as
you die you just click the bottom and
you just go back you know the part where
the quarter hits the Little Hook oil
these kids are out here yeah you just
hit the bottom just keep hitting the
bottom Mark doesn't jam on this thing
yeah he's like where do you put the
quarter but that's also when I realized
I'm not really into games because I was
able to have an orgy and then like we
would go every week and afterwards I
just like oh I was kind of board with it
you're desensitized to great video games
maybe I was able to [__] like [__]
all these arcades and [__]
realistic sports games I never got into
like FIFA Madden NBA 2K or anything
because things like NFL Blitz or NBA Jam
or yeah or punch out you know what I
mean punch out was my jam oh that [__]
was so much more fun it was fun yeah
what about did you guys ever play
Shooters in the arcade oh yeah like
lethal and force crisis my guy the pink
and the blue one right yeah with the
actual [__] and changes those are
cool house of the dead dude that was
sick man attitude was nuts even the
[__] Jurassic Park game
dude those games would [__] rob you
though yeah because it's like two bucks
to play they [__] run can you die
after like five minutes be like here's
15 pterodactyls oh you've lost all your
health oh it looks like you gotta re-up
if you want to keep playing kill the
civilians yeah unrealistic those [__]
pterodactyls and tarantulas at the same
time yeah like what is it and they can
throw axes at you
zombies shoot that ax in the air oh are
there still nickel nickels around or no
I don't know I don't know no bum because
it's not about coins anymore they're
cards so you buy a card for the day oh I
see round one kind of took over round
one round that one's pretty fire there's
a place at Red Rock I take tackle yeah
we go there yeah one of my nieces and
nephews what's it called there's an
arcade but it's like it's for kids but
it's like there's a whole back section
to Red Rock Casino where there's like a
giant movie theater and then uh [__]
arcades and [__] yeah yeah and like they
have like a [__] kid kid Jamboree
thing or whatever like a these DC
discoveries yeah tunnels through all
these tubes and probably smelling vomit
and [__] it's for the parents that want
to just drop the kids off and they can
go Campbell yeah they sign a kid I was
like how long did I leave a kid here and
they're like oh until we close so I
think there's parents are just like here
you go for like 12 hours and then you're
like how long you open like 24 hours
we don't close [__] they are
responsible because we were gonna drop
them off for a couple hours and then
we're like they're like oh if it's their
first time you need an immunization her
I'm like oh [__] these guys are like
legit legit wow huh because he bought
another kid or some [__]
make sure your children don't have
babies no dude so I
I gotta say probably the Elder Scrolls
Oblivion oh Elder scrolling great game
yeah and I used to Rob everyone's houses
and I would I would go in there and then
if if a kid if a kid ever talks [__]
because there's always some kids who
talk [__] in those games I would
immediately save file and then I would
[__] that kid up like like I would kill
them I would lightning bolt them and
[__] save file first though yeah say
file first and then I would loot him too
have you seen any Elder Scrolls what you
want to like rob a store you just pick
up a pot and you put the pot over the
shopkeeper's head and then you just take
everything [__] it up you could do that
and then he's just standing there he
just can't see it
this is like World of Warcraft but
shittier I get slow I try to get in
those games but I just felt like I was
running errands all the time yeah oh you
don't like killing dragons huh well like
I I didn't want like say for The Witcher
right I thought The Witcher was gonna be
sick the first game I played was Witcher
3 and I started playing for like 15
minutes and I was like I gotta go to the
[__] shop I gotta buy these potions
before I fight this Griffin and I was
like dude he's way too much but it's too
much I'm actually with you bro you have
to be in that state of mind of like
wonderment to like really be captivated
yeah bro if you have something to do
that dates and like they give you text
box to read instructions that are this
big and I'm like I'm not reading that
bro I'm not really not reading anything
I'm not reading that and by the way I
gotta read with my finger under it and
[__] I'm
sorry yeah I don't care dude [__] [__]
up I'm here to rob houses I'm here to
yeah cut people's heads up but you got
to team up with a friend
yeah let's run errands together and then
it's fun even playing with a friend
sometimes I'm like ugh I don't even want
to do that I just want to like
I said this yesterday but I'm very
excited on Monday I get the early
release of Hogwarts Legacy oh that's
tight but that's not multiplayer huh I
can't like [__] people up in it I don't
know it's open world but I don't think
so you can bro I think you could [__]
abracadab or something but I wanna
Abracadabra real people and piss them
the [__] off and be like expeller ammos
and dogs dude I think they're there's
gonna be a you would be in utter
Paradise with GTA 5 online and and a a
hacking mod oh yeah oh life's total hell
I would so I did GTA online it was fun I
used to get in my helicopter and I just
land on people's cars
are we playing this together by the way
yeah okay you can log people out of
their account like you could just turn
their whole like the program off that's
kind of incredible dude I used to play
heist with my friends in GTA and they
but they would always play like late at
night and I'd be like the getaway driver
and I would fall asleep bro I would
literally fall asleep with my mic on I'm
like just I don't know like that's
happened three years the real world huh
yeah in real world and I fall asleep and
they're like yo yo what's up what's up
Nick Drive I was playing with Tiff's
cousins bro I was playing with their
cousins and we're like yeah let's do
this [__] Heist this is like a couple
years ago GTA 5 Heist right yeah yeah I
would fall asleep dude I eat one of my
favorite heists to do is the stealth
ones right and it was always going to
take it so far
was like okay I'm you know you have to
like take down security cameras and [__]
like that and I'm like hey guys all
right [__] this guy I'm going live
because that means everyone has to load
again
nobody wants to load again it takes like
18 minutes to load it yeah and then it
takes 18 minutes to load back out oh no
Warzone stuff because you gotta like it
takes so long for you to get in the
[__] Lobby and then you get killed in
the first five minutes and then I go
reload back again you're like oh dude
I'd rather [__] turn my game off but
I love I love using military terms to be
like yeah guy I gotta go live I can't
believe I can't do this
but dude you guys would love if we did
the GTA like simple Heist together it's
like cream when it works like imagine
this like so the way that it works it's
like hey you're gonna be at the jail you
got to get this guy out of the jail I
gotta go to the airport and steal this
plane and we gotta time into that by the
time you're out I pick you up at the
same like um it's like so good dude I
would land on you bro
I'll go live I gotta go live
it's a life right now out I'm willing to
take the risk because that's
entertaining too you guys look at the
same screen like how do you know what
you guys are doing you just have to talk
yeah you got to be like all right pick
it up playing now you can't see what I'm
doing you can't you don't get a small
screen to enjoy what they're doing too
no you have to just focus on your task
and we all have to it's real life bar we
got to communicate on when we're like
unless you just are watching us stream
but dude it's so much fun we can really
do that let's do it and then there's
always the variability
if I get on my PC can I get my Batmobile
I don't think so damn oh dude if you
sign up for GTA online and you already
have a rockstar account you'll get like
free money you just buy another one
we're buying the Batman yeah I'll do
that
foreign